lawyers for the family of Stephon Clark
tells CBS News they plan to file a
federal lawsuit as soon as today or his
death in a police shooting he was
unarmed when two officers killed him on
March 18th hundreds attended the 22 year
olds funeral yesterday and protesters
again took to the streets Jamie yuccas
is in Sacramento with the latest on this
story Jamie good morning good morning
the family also says they'll hold a
press conference here later today at the
South Christian Center to announce
findings of an independent autopsy
meanwhile community leaders are calling
for peace and reconciliation after Clark
was laid to rest yesterday Stefan is
going to live for generations to
generations to generations to generation
an emotional stephane take Clark kissed
his brother Stefan's casket next to a
wreath saying rest in power before
leading the congregation in the chant
I am Stefan Clark police shot at Clark
20 times in his grandmother's backyard
believing the cell phone he was holding
was a gun the reverend al sharpton
criticized the White House for calling
the shooting a local matter no this is
not a local matter they've been killing
young black men all over the country
Stefan Clark did not choose violence
that night after the funeral Clark
family attorney Ben Crump called for
peace we must choose non-violence to
make sure that we protest in the most
productive way possible black lives
matter protesters blocked intersections
as they marched through downtown
Sacramento but they did not target the
NBA Stadium where the Kings were playing
as they had twice before outside the
arena
Savanti Clark was seen shaking hands
with police the Kings announced
Wednesday that they will partner with
black lives matter to fund youth
programs and bring transformational
change to the city's black communities
is that a big deal to have a pro sports
team oh my god that's
huge a lot of people keep asking why did
you go shut down the golden one Center
that's why I look at what happens so
protest works tonight Kings players are
set to attend a youth voice forum for
healing and hundreds are expected to
attend Anthony Jamie yuccas thanks Jamie